Hey Jocko.
I'm a 35 year old and have a physically demanding job.
I've been a dry Waller for about 14 years.
Work about eight to 10 hours a day.
When it comes to working out,
I'm finding it really hard to maintain discipline to continue as it seen as it
seems.
I burnout also have two boys under the age of four,
so I sleep like you do.
I can relate men.
I'm wondering if I'm just being a pussy and need to push through the burnout or
take a different approach to working out when I burned out,
my body just feels weird as well as my head.
I tend to get depressed and find it hard to even go to work.
Just throwing this out there for maybe some tips to get over this so I can stay
focused and consistent.
Thanks.
Okay,
so hang in drywall or you ever hung drywall before?
No.
Yes.
Okay.
I better know what the answer means.
I've been in a drywall hanging scenario scenario.
Yes,
but I didn't do the hanging of the drywall.
Okay.
Yeah.
That does not qualify as a little bit
wrong.
You do not get called.
I get it for drywall.
If you've seen it being hard.
I appreciate what you're trying to say,
but that doesn't work then you can dry wall is hard work.
Yes sir.
It uses a bunch of different muscles in your body and of course when you get
better at it,
because I'm not good at it.
When I,
when I hung dry,
when I hang drywall,
if I'm doing a project,
I'm not good at it.
If you see someone that's good at,
like this guy that's been hanging drywall for 14 years,
he's a master.
He's,
he's holding one hand slapping nails him.
He's your dry wall screws on stilts.
Guys work on stilts.
You ever seen that before?
No.
So good.
Drywallers they're on stilts because they don't,
they're just boom,
slap it up there.
So,
but it's hard.
You're doing,
you're basically doing a clean,
kind of pulled the drywall up,
you're pushing it up or you're using your grip strength in the drywall.
Then you're doing overhead presses cause you dry wall ceilings sometimes.
So,
and it's eight to 10 hours plus,
not to mention you're,
you're bending down picking stuff up all day.
So it's eight to 10 hours of squats,
cleans and overhead presses with grip work.
So you're doing that eight to 10 hours a day.
So you're getting good physical work throughout the day.
Now look man,
if you're that drained then first of all let's check the Diet.
Let's make sure that we're not on the job site and the donut truck arrives and
you're,
you're going belly up to the donut truck with a monster for monster energy
drinks.
Like to keep you going through day,
that's going to hurt you.
So check the Diet.
It's the good thing is check a diet and then if you have to just bring your
food,
don't let you know your bro that's going to run down to Mickey D's to grab lunch
cause you didn't pack anything that's going to jack you up.
So all that stuff will make you feel weak and out of sorts and all that.
That being said,
it's still,
you're working hard all day.
You're doing hard physical labor all day.
You also,
I mean you can see construction workers were dry walls.
You can see people that are due that hard labor all day and they don't look like
they're in shape,
right?
There may be their fat,
maybe they're just,
they don't look like they're in shape.
Let's cause their diet sucks.
Generally they're coming home and they're getting on their,
their 12 pack of beer and pizza.
So get your Diet,
make sure your dad's good to go.
And then what I would do is,
and I've worked construction before and we'll even big projects on my house
where I'm working all day long.
Remodelling pulling down drywall,
putting up drywall,
demo in rooms,
whatever.
Uh,
I still do a workout.
Now what you're going to do though is do something that is going to compliment
what you've done during the day.
So you're getting some pretty good strength work at this point.
You're getting,
you're getting cleaned,
your grip work,
you're doing all this hard work all throughout the day.
So maybe what you'd need to do is do some more cardiovascular at night or maybe
it's just like a really good stretching routine cause you got your strength and
you got your cardio do during the day.
Like if I think about how much I sweat when I'm working on a house project,
I'm going to fall off,
let it sweat.
So that means I'm working hard.
So find what can you do that's going to compliment the conditioning that you're
getting from your actual labor.
And maybe in your case it might just be like straight up mobility.
It might be straight up mobility.
Like,
Hey,
you're just doing some good stretching,
you're doing some MobilityWOD.
Uh,
that's mobility workout of the day.
You can go to that website.
They got really good stuff on there to to loosen up and make sure you're staying
limber.
Because another thing you find with construction guys is they end up with some,
you know,
with a bad back with a bad,
they get tendinitis from swinging a hammer all day or holding.
So you can get those kind of use overuse injuries.
And Yeah.
So I would look at what you can do that's going to compliment that.
Also,
maybe you feel like maybe you just need to do some heavy lifting because you're
lifting something little all day.
You know you're lifting drywall all day so you're getting some good endurance,
muscular endurance,
but maybe just come home and do,
do a couple sets of heavy dead lifts are a couple of sets of heavy squats.
And the other thing here is like when we're on deployment,
when I was back in the,
when I was in the military,
when we're on deployment,
we wouldn't be doing workouts that are going to give you the,
the four days of delayed onset,
muscular soreness,
right?
You're not going to hurt locker is you're not going to put you in the pain
locker where,
hey I did squats yesterday.
Oh Echo just got shot.
I can't help him too tired to sword broken.
Someone grab echo cause my legs were super sore.
My quads are hurting from front squats yesterday.
So that's not what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about doing some something that's heavy,
but it's quick and you're not,
you know,
you're not going crazy and doing so many sets that you're going to build up all
kinds of lactic acid and make your legs all sore.
So maybe it's something that,
but I would say explore all that.
Look what you can find that's gonna make you,
that's going to compliment you and what you do at work.
And also you could look at some Jujitsu,
you know,
look at some Jujitsu,
Jujitsu,
although at first it's a crazy muscular workout,
a full body workout like you've never had before because you're resisting every
part of your movement and you'll be sore your entire body.
But then as you get better at it,
you can relax more.
That takes like a year,
year and a half,
maybe even two years before you can really start to relax.
The thing that's cool about that for you is you've got two kids under the age of
four,
so maybe in two or three years they're ready to start training to now you've got
to have something to share with them a little bit.
In the Jujitsu,
so yeah.
Don't kill yourself.
Find something that compliments your work.
And if that's just stretching,
man,
just stretch.
Yeah.
And maybe you don't.
I used to do it,
uh,
when I was at team to team Tiwi soon do,
we used to run all the time.
It was every day.
It was like,
oh,
Monday,
PT in Iran,
Tuesday swimming or run Wednesday,
obstacle course and Iran,
Thursday,
I forget what it was.
And then Friday was a long run.
It was like a 12 mile runner,
10 mile run on Fridays.
So what I would do is I would get done with work on Friday or get done with a PT
on Friday,
and usually we'd be like half,
half day frogman Friday.
Sure.
Strongly on Friday.
Get some prewar,
no war going on.
Guess what you do on Friday afternoon and the trims you're gonna go,
you know,
get after with your boys
in the bar and the bar.
Sure.
Well,
yeah,
frontline Friday frogman Friday,
then frogman Friday kind of went away once September 11th happened,
so,
but this is pre September 11th frogman Fridays.
So we get done with work at noon and I would just Friday go down and hit my
squats and then so Friday I'd heal up Saturday and Sunday back to work on
Sunday.
Ready to rock and roll.
Yeah.
So maybe you hit just do a good workout on Friday.
Good hard workout on Friday.
He'll up over the weekend.
You're feeling good Monday back in the game.
But yeah,
hard labor.
Yeah.
Requires something a little bit different than those of you that are sitting at
a desk looking at a computer screen like Echo Charles.
Yes sir.
Yeah.
You can do different kinds of workout when you do that all day for sure.
You mentioned the Diet.
I would say with 99% certainty,
I would say I don't know everybody.
Right.
I understand that 99% certainty that
if you have a good day and not even have immaculate good diet and you're working
drywall construction moving,
as you know,
I used to be a mover for a little bit.
Yeah.
If you have a good diet,
I mean you watched moving
cause apparently in your mind that qualifies for you know it just total victory.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Oh yeah.
I know you were an actual yeah but I wasn't the best mover.
I was one on one anyway.
That's a,
that's a whole nother thing anyway.
If you have a good diet and you're doing this kind of work,
that is your workout essentially and it's a long one.
It's probably a hard to work out than most people's normal workouts you do.
And that's the thing.
You're so right because when you're working eight,
10 hours a day,
there's a lot of work to be done.
So your lunch break is like,
Dang this is,
I'm going to go to get some delicious,
you know,
to this food truck right here or this,
Mcdonald's or wherever,
wherever.
It's not,
you know,
you,
but you get a good diet with this kind of stuff.
You essentially have a great workout along with a good diet.
You're going to get results.
Just that.
And in a way you won't even really have to do these supplemental work house
unless you have different goals.
So if you're like,
um,
okay I'm just going to do my work,
I'm going to have a good diet and then I stretch afterwards,
which is such a good idea when you call day,
same motion all day stretch,
you know,
get all that probably you'll be way better.
You'll feel way better to him.
You'd be surprised how much easier the work becomes with that diet.
And also maybe there's,
like I said,
you need to look for what compliments it with dry wall.
I don't,
I don't know.
You know,
it's probably not dead lifting cause you're left lifting stuff all day.
But maybe it's just like some hardcore like Ab core strength that you're going
to work,
you're going to,
you know,
and that's going to strengthen your lower back.
It's going to offset all the pressure that you put it on your back all day.
So maybe it's that,
maybe it's,
you know,
pull ups cause you're not really pulling yourself up.
So,
so maybe you're doing two workouts,
maybe you're doing like one workout on Fridays you do an abs and pull ups and
then during the week you're doing a 20 minute stretch session to really make
sure your hips are opened up.
Right.
Of course,
like them guys from 10th Plan as your Shit's got to be flexible.
They're flexible.
That's the,
you have to be,
you have to be able to do Lotus to get your black belt from Eddie Bravo.
There you go.
I can't do the Lotus.
I can't get my black belt from Eddie Bravo.
No,
no,
no.
You can't.
No,
sorry bro.
I should be able to do that at some point.
Depends on what you mean by should,
but yeah,
man.
Cool.
Do the Lotus and then work on that and you know,
report back.
But yeah,
the Diet thing,
I think the Diet thing that's going to be 75 if not more percent issue.
They say,
Oh,
you don't sleep enough and how can,
how do you not say,
don't eat crap.
You don't need as much sleep.
Yeah.
Check that out.
Give that one a try.
Yeah.
And,
and lists,
let's face it,
there's people can be different with the requirements.
You're obviously,
you know,
like if I said,
Hey Jocko,
you're in prison for,
I dunno,
whatever.
And you have eight hours of sleep sleep for eight hours,
which basically,
I don't know if you can do that.
Deployed on a ship multiple times,
three shipboard deployments as a seal.
And when you're a seal on a ship,
you have no job.
You don't like the,
that are the guys that are in the regular navy that are driving the ship and
maintaining the ship and steering the ship and all that.
They have a job.
We have no job.
And so what we,
we could either sleep,
eat or Lyft and that's a raised seal,
stood for sleep,
eat and lift.
But some guys would sleep a lot.
I wouldn't sleep a lot.
He had some guys that had like sleep disorders.
There was a guy that slept for like 29 hours,
but they need to wake up and stay awake for 32 hours and then he'd go back to
bed.
So yeah,
it was kind of weird.
Circadian Rhythm was whale.
Yeah.
And then that happens too on a ship because you can stay inside the ship with no
song for forever if you want to.
We used to,
we used to go out as much as we could on the deck of the ship.
Yeah.
Get a Sun Tan and then do PT.
Sure.
That too.
But yeah,
I think you,
yeah,
you sleep different and you know,
some eight hour in,
actually I've done the thing where I got used to only getting like six,
six and a half,
and it,
it started to work.
Like I said,
I need them,
you know,
I didn't like that.
I tried to go back to,
actually I only get six,
maybe seven now anyway,
because the kids think anyway,
the Diet I think will I for real thing.
I believe this a fact,
75% or more solution to the whole problem,
the Diet clean up the is good.
When your lunch stay away from the Mickey D's.
Yeah.
Stay away from all that stuff.